cuál de los valores de x hace que el
paro ordenado x menos 2 sea una solución
del sistema de desigualdades
representados por la siguiente gráfica
que es esta vamos a ver esto con más
detalle y nos están restringiendo a
todas las formas que sean x coma menos 2
o lo que es lo mismo nos estamos
restringiendo a que ye sea igual a menos
2 y si nos restringimos a que sea igual
a menos 2 qué valor debe tomar x para
que se conserve el sistema de
desigualdades los invito a que pausa en
el vídeo y observen esta gráfica de aquí
y elijan alguna de las opciones bueno
vamos a resolver esto juntos vamos a
comprender esto claramente si yo
eligiera por ejemplo este punto de acá
este punto no hay solución de ninguna de
estas gráficas de ninguna de las
desigualdades para que sea solución
tiene que encontrarse en el área
sombreada de ambas así que ésta no es
solución
punto de aquí tampoco es solución de
ninguno de los sistemas de desigualdad
ya que este de aquí es una línea
punteada lo que quiere decir que la
solución no se encuentra o no incluye
los puntos sobre esta línea así que sí
este punto está sobre esta línea no es
parte de la solución si ésta fuera una
línea continua esta línea verde entonces
este punto si sería parte de la solución
pero como es una línea punteada pues no
es parte de la solución ahora si
consideráramos este punto de aquí este
punto sí sería solución para la
desigualdad que tenemos hombre de en
verde pero no satisface la desigualdad
que tenemos en azul por lo que este
punto no satisface el sistema de
desigualdades ambas desigualdades
ahora si viéramos este punto de aquí
este sí satisface ambas
desigualdades ya que está dentro del
área de la desigualdad en verde
está sobre la línea de la desigualdad
azul pero esta es una línea continua
quiere decir que lo que está sobre la
línea también se incluye como parte de
la solución así que este punto si es
solución de la desigualdad azul y de la
desigualdad verde así que esto está en
la solución del sistema de desigualdades
también en este punto de aquí está en la
solución del sistema de desigualdades
este punto también es solución y esto es
porque estos puntos todos estos puntos
se encuentran dentro de la solución de
la desigualdad verde que es todo lo que
está debajo de esta línea y además se
encuentran en la solución de la
desigualdad azul que es todo lo
iluminado de azul abajo incluyendo esta
línea recuerden que esta área sombreada
verde también incluye esta parte de acá
de hecho esto es donde coinciden ambas
soluciones ahora que ya comprendimos
mejor qué es lo que está pasando aquí
vamos a resolver el problema que nos
piden ahora voy a indicar
la línea que coincide con igual a menos
2 todos los puntos que tienen una e
igual a menos 2 así que esta línea es
igual a menos 2
y si es igual a menos 2 cuáles puntos
satisfacen el sistema de desigualdades
que tiene que cumplirse para x de manera
que se cumpla el sistema de
desigualdades que tenemos aquí vamos a
tomar todos los valores de x que estén a
la derecha de este punto incluyéndolo y
digo que incluye a este punto porque
este punto está sobre la línea azul y la
línea azul es una línea continua
indicando que todos los puntos sobre
esta línea también son solución de
nuestra desigualdad azul y también de la
verde así que todo lo que se encuentre a
partir de este punto y a la derecha va a
ser parte de la solución con la
restricción de que es igual a menos 2
así que todo esto de aquí también es
parte de nuestro conjunto de soluciones
por lo que si nuestras es igual a menos
2 nuestra x nuestra x tiene que ser
mayor o igual porque estamos incluyendo
este punto
-3 y vemos nuestras opciones y
justamente esta opción es la correcta
x es mayor o igual que menos 3 vamos a
hacer otro problema
y ahora en lugar de restringir allí
vamos a restringir a x nos preguntan
cuáles valores de hacen que el paro
ordenado 4g sea una solución al sistema
de desigualdades representada en la
siguiente gráfica y nuevamente los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolver esto por su cuenta
ahora vamos a resolverlo juntos así que
ahora nos están restringiendo a que x
sea igual a 4 y x igual a 4 es
justamente
esta línea de acá
nos restringimos a todos los puntos que
están sobre esta línea pero que también
tienen que ser solución al sistema de
desigualdades así que queremos
mantenernos en esta área de aquí que es
donde se sobreponen las soluciones al
sistema de desigualdades por lo que si
nos restringimos a que x es igual a 4
vamos a querer aquellos puntos de iu que
estén por encima pero que no toquen a
esta línea verde es una línea punteada
lo que indica que los puntos en esta
línea no son parte de la solución de la
desigualdad verde entonces deben estar
por encima de este punto pero sin
incluirlo así que nuestra ley tiene que
ser mayor pero no igual a menos 1
entonces vamos de aquí de menos 1 hacia
y hasta donde llegamos llegamos a tres
así que nuestra puede ser igual a tres o
menor que tres incluimos este punto
porque en esta línea azul tenemos una
línea continua que nos indica que los
puntos sobre esta línea también son
parte de la solución de la desigualdad
azul así que este punto si lo incluimos
por lo que nuestra hierba ya que damos
mayor que menos 1 pero menor o igual que
3 menor o igual que 3 si nuestra
restricción es de x 4 entonces nuestra y
va de mayor a menos 1 hasta menor igual
a 3 y ahora veamos cuál de nuestras
opciones coincide con que es mayor que
menos 1 y menor o igual a 3 y justo aquí
la tenemos esta es nuestra primera
opción la correcta